I think we should be able to have a look
now at some pictures that we have got of
Russia sunac meeting with King Charles
there they are at Buckingham Palace all
smiles the two men as they meet and of
course King Charles formerly invites
which is soon after form a new
government well let's bring in our
events commentator Alistair Bruce shall
we the picture there of them shaking
hands
it is the start of the audience that the
king will have given and will have now
proceeded probably towards its close
it's quite moving to the first time that
the king receives someone and invites
them to form a government and we
remember the photograph quite recently
of his mother the queen inviting Richard
sunax predecessor not so long ago up at
Balmoral but for the king a chance to
talk and he always allows the chance of
pictures to be taken before the doors
are closed and it would have been behind
closed doors that the King Alone with
Rishi sunak would have invited him to
become the head of government and to
give him therefore as Sovereign the
leadership of the executive of the
United Kingdom photographs now just
released
and Alistair I'm always so fascinated to
know what goes on with these audiences
but they're always so
tightly controlled aren't we just get
the briefest of statements from the
palace and just giving us a facts on
what took place with Liz Strauss earlier
today but Prime Ministers really value
them don't they and I'm sure that will
be no different
the palace always balances the fact that
there is public interest in seeing the
meeting of the head of state and the
head of government but also that this is
a very private moment so you have to
balance those by getting the photograph
at the beginning and these photographs
were clearly taken as the king received
Rishi sunak right after he'd been
introduced to him by the kings of query
Lieutenant Colonel Johnny Thompson but
then you know once those doors are
closed and until any prime minister
breaks the code we're just not going to
know what goes on we know
constitutionally that the King has the
right to know what is going on he has
the privilege of being able to give
warning or to take advice or or even to
just in every way interrogate the Prime
Minister but also the Prime Minister has
a chance to talk in complete confidence
with a sort of avuncular figure of his
Sovereign and that relationship is
perhaps the only place a prime minister
can find that kind of confidentiality so
so these photographs do Mark the
beginning of a relationship between head
of government with the head of state the
King which will take its Journey forward
and it's going to be such a challenging
leadership and Premiership by Richie
sunac as prime minister and I'm sure all
the way through the king will be deeply
conscious of his constitutional position
as head of state and wanting that the
progress be done in the most effective
way for the benefit of all people who
live in the United Kingdom